[Music]
here's a video I am very excited about
if you watched my Instagram or any
social media which you should you know I
like whisky and my favorite is Japanese
whisky which we're gonna drink today
hella Gameboy it's one of those videos
where I don't know if this is a good
idea but I just want to drink some
whiskey so I thought we'd start with the
Japanese type whiskey it's personally my
favorite probably a little little biased
because I love Japan okay so left side
we have yeah the Santori whiskey
nevermind
there you go and right side we have the
knee actually this doesn't belong we had
the Nika Nika whiskey those are the two
big distilleries or companies rather
sorry in Japan
Suntory and Nika they're all very
different but the first one ever made
was the Yamazaki and I have a 12 year
old one which is very nice very nice and
then we have an 18 year old one which
I've never even tried before I've never
had 18 year old aged whiskey so I'm
really excited
Oh Suntory you may have heard of from
the the movie lost in translation when
Bill Murray's and the issue in the
commercial and he's like for relaxing
times make it Suntory time so I thought
we'd start with Yamazaki because it's
the oldest of oldest it's from 1923 it's
started so it's it's the oldest I think
it's the oldest distillery in Japan I
don't know for sure I'm curious if I
will tell the difference between the
12-year and 18 I had this one before
it's very nice but I'll just say that
about any whiskey really it's very nice
it's given me a very sweet palette for
me I'll just be like it's very nice
I like how they keep their bottles
simple this [ __ ] that's it okay get
in there and don't be an ass girl we're
gonna we have a lot of stuff to try so
let's just that's very nice
it's gonna oaky taste to it very very
beautiful I will give it seven very nice
'as we have the 18 years let's just get
the big guns out right away
very nice got the Suntory in the back 18
years this bottle yes how much it
customized it damn it did I tell you
it's 500 it's pretty crazy
I think in Japan you'll get it for like
hundred and twenty I never spent this
much nearly on a whiskey I'm like
nervous even trying no it smells it's
beautiful
[Music]
you can definitely tell a difference
much smoother takes you can really feel
it more it's just beautiful whisky very
nice very nice
I'm liking this this is fun the next one
that came out was the Hibiki this is not
H whiskey it's sort of cheap and I think
it's a blend as well a meticulous blend
of the finest whiskey but Hibiki is very
good I think a lot if you know Japanese
whiskey you'll definitely know about
Hibiki I should probably pour a little
less we got a lot of whiskies to go
through I was gonna make it for the
video but I started perfectly I mean
they all taste very nice it gives the
the aftertaste it's sort of a taste that
hits you when you have it in your mouth
and then there's a taste when you
swallow that it's so much more superior
in this one compared to the Hibiki even
though the taste of the mole is actually
quite similar Maya can you be quiet or
you want some whiskey then we have the
hakuchu they just in the forest hence
the green bottle and all that [ __ ]
third hakushi hakuchu catyph all love
the bottle isn't it beautiful
yeah I love it it's very it's got a very
light color to it this is the last one
of the century
that flavor is so different I really
like the hakushi I think I'll get an H
one of that next time I think it's the
same thing here since this isn't aged
you you're not hit by that taste
afterwards the same way that I like this
is very nice I give this one seven we're
very nice is eight very nice as seven
burn Isis this is a six very nice now
we're moving on to the Nika which
unfortunately I only got two of them and
one I I finished I have a little look a
little bit laughter this one yochi was
the first one they made so Nika was made
by the legendary whiskey Japanese maker
taka sure his name must Soraka Tucket
syrup so this guy was like I want to
make whiskey so he went to Scotland to
study it and that has met he met his
main [ __ ] reader and then who was also
studying making whisky then they went
back to Japan and he joined the Santori
team and he's like now [ __ ] you guys
i'ma make my own brand so he made me kit
and the first one they did was your Chi
1934 so santora's older but nee I think
Nika is it's cooler
so they made yo Chi and they try to
recreate the
the same thing they did in Scotland the
same condition they have it there it's
unmade on the island like the southern
island I think which is just as big as
Scotland by the coast they wanted it to
be as authentic to Scot it Scotch as
possible and Scotch is literally just
whisky but it's made in Scotland yeah
but they has to be that just to be
called the Scotch the problem only
tastes good because I left too much air
in this bottle you shouldn't do that
yeah I got nothing in here well it was
good I finished it welcome to all
monetize my alcoholism oh yo she gets
eight and a half very nice this damn
they bite your tongue very nice eight
and a half I would almost say it's
better than this one and this is a cheap
one it's not aged the other one I have
is the Nica coffee mall which if you
like whiskey I recommend you try it out
it's very different it's not coffee it's
named after the Korea one of the
investors or something like that but I
feel like it tastes like coffee I might
be paranoid I feel that I thought it was
out so it's like coffee flavor
it's made from corn mainly it's cheap as
well if you want to get something so I
don't want to mess up the facts I feel
bad if I like get something wrong I
probably got some stuff wrong but yeah
that's the coffee one if I remember
correct it has mine smells beautiful
I think it's not so nice
I don't know if I even can tell them I'm
part at this point they're all so good
I'll give it seven very nice I guess it
gets a strong seven very nice so this is
a blend single malt
single malt single malt single mom so
it's made from the same which one this
one is a blend
single malt didn't used to be very
popular when they started these it
wasn't really a thing but now it's like
if you want a good whiskey you probably
want a single Moll I think there's a lot
of great blends as well don't get don't
get me wrong which actually brings me to
the final which is that to go cheap
which I couldn't find any information
about it's sort of a mysterious bottle
they actually don't have their own
distillery they they don't whoa this is
18 years I don't even know so I have @ht
you'll see it has a Canadian writing on
it that's because they import from
Scotland and Canada whiskey and then
they master fully blending into the Togo
Chee I love it look at the ball is so
beautiful it's sort of has it if I
remember correctly he has like a grassy
taste to it which doesn't sound good but
it's it's very I'm so glad I didn't
finish this bottle hey this one grew on
me I didn't really love it in the
beginning but then okay
[Music]
yeah it just has this weird taste like
nature it's really good it's so
different from any of these like these
like it I couldn't really probably tell
apart to be honest this one definitely
has a unique I can't believe it's 18
years I had no idea that's crazy so that
concludes my Japanese whiskey we got the
Suntory
we got the Nika I wish I brought more
Nika my favorite Nika is the Nika from
Beryl
I really recommend that one check it out
if you want if you're like I don't know
which one to get I want to start try
that one it's very good it's got a lot
of alcohol in it got a good kick to it
now we're gonna do the test I feel like
you'll have to set up the blind test I
mean the color is already a dead
giveaway isn't it there's one is darker
isn't it or maybe if I had the guests
just looking I would say this is the
eighteen and this is the twelve so why
don't we start with this one I don't
want to mess this up it's like 50/50
[Music]
it's good it's so good you can tell yeah
I can tell there's Yamazaki because it
has that cherry
it's not even cherries well you can
taste the casket which doesn't sound
good at all but strong flavoring this
one actually maybe that will stay 18
years one I don't know I don't know I
need to try this one come on what do I
win okay it's hard
here's it thing I want to go with my
intuition which tells me this is the
twelve year one no the opposite the
flavor is telling me this is 18 okay
this is Daisy
I got it okay for real I get a lot of
questions like oh I want to try whiskey
I don't I tried
Jack Daniels and I tried Jameson but
it's that's like saying oh I like
burgers but I'm I love I'm trying
McDonald's and Burger King listen
there's this whole beautiful world
waiting for you okay Santori and Nica
thank you both god bless you Japan god
bless you thank you very much
leave a like if you enjoyed I don't know
if this even is a minute alright thank
you for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed and I wanted to do scotch and
eggs so let me know if you want me to
actually do that and you Jitsu just some
squad time jujitsu bye